usted o alguien que usted quiere ha sido
diagnosticado con cáncer de próstata
este vídeo le ayudará a entender cómo el
cáncer de próstata afecta a su cuerpo
la próstata es una glándula en los
hombres que produce parte del líquido
seminal
se encuentra justo debajo de la vejiga
delante de la última parte del intestino
grueso llamada recto la próstata se
envuelve alrededor de parte de la uretra
que es el tubo que envía a la orina y el
semen fuera del cuerpo la mayoría de los
cánceres de próstata comienzan en los
pequeños sacos dentro de la glándula
prostática que fabrica el líquido
prostático
aquí se forman células cancerosas a
partir de las células glandulares que
recubren los alveolos con el tiempo las
células cancerosas pueden multiplicarse
y formar un tumor maligno o canceroso
sin embargo la mayoría de los cánceres
de próstata crece más lentamente que
otros tipos de cáncer un riesgo
importante para el cáncer de próstata es
la edad el cáncer de próstata es más
común en hombres mayores de 65 años
la raza es otro factor de riesgo el
cáncer de próstata es más común en los
hombres afroamericanos que en cualquier
otra raza
el riesgo también es mayor en los
hombres cuyos parientes como un padre o
un hermano tienen antecedentes de cáncer
de próstata
generalmente el cáncer de próstata
temprano no presenta síntomas sin
embargo cuando el tumor aumenta el
tamaño de la próstata es posible que
tengan los siguientes síntomas
dificultad para iniciar la micción
micción débil interrumpida o dolorosa
necesidad de orinar con frecuencia
especialmente por la noche
eyaculación dolorosa
problemas para conseguir una erección
sangre en la orina o en el semen y dolor
o rigidez en la espalda baja las caderas
o la pelvis
tenga en cuenta que estos síntomas
pueden ser causados por un agrandamiento
de la próstata que no es cáncer
si usted tiene cáncer de próstata el
médico tendrá que determinar la
calificación y la etapa o la progresión
de la enfermedad
cada calificación se basa en el aspecto
normal que tiene el tejido de la
próstata bajo un microscopio
el sistema de calificación del cáncer de
próstata se llama sistema de
clasificación de gleason
en este sistema se toman muestras de dos
áreas principales del tumor y se les
asigna una calificación de 1 a 5
las calificaciones se suman para darle
al cáncer una clasificación de gleason
entre 2 y 10 cuanto mayor sea la
puntuación de gleision más probable es
que el cáncer crezca y se propague a
otras zonas cada etapa del cáncer de
próstata se basa en la cantidad de
cáncer que tiene y donde se encuentra
las etapas están numeradas de 1 a 4 en
la etapa 1 el tumor no se ha diseminado
fuera de la próstata en la etapa 2 el
cáncer está más avanzado pero todavía se
encuentra solo en la próstata
en la etapa 3 el cáncer se ha diseminado
más allá de la capa externa de la
próstata y en la etapa 4 el cáncer se ha
diseminado a los tejidos cercanos así
como áreas más distantes del cuerpo
si se enfrenta a un diagnóstico de
cáncer de próstata continúe conversando
con su médico y su equipo de atención
del cáncer